[Music]
welcome back
to off the record where we talk about
careful things that we won't get in
trouble for on the internet aka careful
boys
welcome back to careful boys where we
talk about safe things safe things that
don't get us in trouble things that we
won't get in trouble for on the
interwebs and today we have lauren's cow
with us
hey guys let's talk about some safe
stuff 20 21 guys hello children what do
we call it when there's a woman sitting
in that seat careful uh careful genders
careful
careful careful peoples their full
equity careful equity
yeah is that too far no i just punch
them in the face because it's all about
equality
careful boys and [ __ ] yeah because of
[ __ ] and i punch them in the face
they're the representative of boys
b-o-i-z so it's like none what's the
b-y-z
that's good for boys oh like the boys in
the hood i know b-o-i-s is like boys
like that's like illinois
idaho oh i see that oh makes sense yeah
yeah college football you got to feel
like a z in there
it's like king does with a z or g oh
here we go we bit the jab walking is
that we wanted to be more than always
bringing up jab walking always off
camera always bringing up that vlog
remember have you never been to a strip
club yeah let's talk about that let's
talk about it yeah never been why i just
never had none of your boys had like a
bachelor party or anything like that no
you just refused to go
it was always the guys in relationships
that were like oh we gotta go to uh the
strip club for your birthday
and i'm all like why
and then they use me as an excuse and
i'm like once you get there you find out
whatever yeah
and they're the ones that [ __ ] do all
this [ __ ] and i'll tell you right now
anybody here
for an excuse
let them they need it
birthday they took me to a strip club
and then they bought me a lap dance and
i was like that's it did you like it
yeah and meanwhile they have like five
thousand dollar private room stuff in
the back yeah they had a good time they
spent hundreds of money strip clubs are
like
graduations you don't [ __ ] celebrate
graduation for yourself because you put
in work you celebrate graduations for
your family so your parents can like be
proud of something same thing strip
clubs you don't actually go for you
right you
you're going to go for your friends
you go for your friends who are in
relationships and your other friends
that get no action from women exactly
i took a buddy to a bachelor party this
is like i don't know a decade ago and we
go and he gets 14 lap dances holy [ __ ]
he's the guy getting married by the way
did he bust nuts in his khakis i mean
bro 14 i've never seen someone get so
many lap dances ever and we all just
kept paying for his lap dances so by the
end of the night we counted up 14. i'm
like dude you [ __ ] cheated bro yeah
dude
you're a cheating piece of [ __ ] is there
a limit though of like at what point
where you go man that's no longer a meal
that's a buffet double digits is [ __ ]
cheating bro that is crazy well
is it
14 separate girls or was it like one
girl maybe like did a really good job
coercing him to like eight songs in a
row there was definitely some double dip
double dipping for sure but not the same
girl every time
not say you know i'm an analyst in this
field or anything like that but you know
they they're really smart with their
song choice thing because you know it's
like a lap dance if you didn't know a
lap dance is a song so like when the
song plays it's like it's usually just
like the hook or in the verse or even
shorter than that definitely like the
radio reader
it's like the karaoke version yeah how
would you curate my my first strip club
experience like what would you do it's
got to be vegas it's better than la
vegas well but it's really good too
because i heard that it's a brothel when
you like really have no expectations
your standards are like really really
low ellie's like kind of tight and it's
called hong kong i heard hong kong yeah
that's the strip club in t1 i heard hong
kong i heard about that and i heard it's
not a strip club it's a brothel it's not
a stripper strip club oh because my
friend was like about this spot but my
friend was a friend i've never been i
just went on a bachelor party and they
were talking about it oh right well they
were talking about tijuana's
interesting where'd you go
so originally we were supposed to go to
lake tahoe
but it caught on fire
was it two weeks ago because i was about
to go too it was two weeks ago and then
uh and they were like oh you know what
like let's they're from atlanta so
they're like yeah let's go to san
francisco i'm like all right okay cool
let's go san francisco but they don't
really know the general area that well
so they they they sent like the airbnb
to the group me and it was san jose
what
you know dude dude this is not san
francisco so we went to san jose so we
were in san jose for like three days for
a bachelor party yeah for a bachelor
party we did go into san francisco for a
little bit were they vietnamese
um no
filipino
okay we had some good fun you know the
san francisco the san francisco 49ers
play in cupertino california do you
think san francisco has kind of uh
expanded if you will
oh [ __ ] but call in san jose san
francisco that's like calling san diego
la yeah yeah yeah and there's nothing to
do in san jose so that's true
so what'd you guys do we drove into the
city a little bit um
you went to the strip club we had a lamb
party that i'll be pissed at you guys if
that was my dancers to the to the house
oh sick there you go yeah
that's the naked ones
not the maids just like yeah but they
strip yeah oh time did they have a porta
pool it was funny though because they
would do games like
glow sticks just glow stick games
they're like
with the
is funny so what happens is uh someone
gets an erection and they get up no no
so what they do uh so obviously a lot of
house calls will always they uh they
number one house calls they don't send
one girl by themselves they always have
to have a buddy system for like safety
and all that stuff right uh and then
they both show up and then they like get
straight to the point because they
always know they're gonna be in in a
room full of probably like eight plus
like [ __ ] loser guys
the loser guy yeah it's a super junk
it's like a bachelor that's like
whispering it's like a bunch of kids
you're like like kids like yeah hey yeah
are we gonna play some games don't be
shy we're gonna do this they're trying
to collect their money right
and then there there's this [ __ ] ring
toss game we're gonna play ring toss and
so they pull out a bunch of those like
uh little raver glow stick things that
you can like snap into you know
and attach and make necklaces and [ __ ]
and then they take one that they keep as
just a stick and then they go over to
a couch and they'll go ahead first and
do it like a little just yoga pose oh
sticks put in their ass pick a stick of
light stick wait in the crack or inside
the hole in the crack hole maybe
whatever's holding at your rack yeah
whatever can hold it up and then yeah
yeah yeah and then you gotta all the
guys all you guys got to get into a line
somewhere with like a drone line there's
rules to this [ __ ] because you know
we're organizing logistical and stuff
and you take you know a ring and then
you connect it as a glowstick ring and
then you do a ring top
and we're just ring tossing like
horseshoes how have i never heard of
this is hilarious this is amazing and
then if you and if you make it there's
oftentimes a prize like what do they do
dance or whatever and
they fart and shoot the glow stick out
when we were when we were doing it like
she was doing it in a circle we're all
sitting around like this surrounding her
and then we were throwing it in and then
someone was like
it it built up and then someone was like
yeah shang chi in the ten rings
and then like
and then one of the other dudes right
dude that's a good advertisement out of
the movie that's actually good again
you guys at home haven't seen shanghai
now you have to go see it one of the
other dudes gets like
he gets a private later right he asked
one of the girls for a private later in
the other room and so like he's getting
a private and then this girl like put
like put like the rings like in her you
know like you know in her bra
because she wasn't stripping it and then
he was saying how like he was she was
like yeah do you mind if they're in here
and he was like yeah that's fine but
then the whole time he was just like
thinking about shang chi in the ten
rings and then he just he couldn't hold
it together he's like all right yeah we
can't do this anymore so
was he cry like laughing the whole time
so he just killed the whole horny vibes
he yes he the vibe was killed you know
there were no
it's like there are no horny vibes yeah
the whole time it's just like there's
always one guy that's the horned body
yeah yeah it's always just good times
and then like you know you got you give
them you got to respect them they're
doing their job you typically
you [ __ ] feed them you offer water
yeah you give them water and then they
need to change in a regular room or
something you like really try your best
to not be like all sexually weird but at
the end of the day because they're there
for such sexual reasons you're you're
actually being even creepier by being so
[ __ ] weird maybe maybe that's why i
can't hire a stripper because i think
i'm gonna be the horny vibe guy i really
don't think you would
you could smell who's gonna be the horny
vibe i am yeah bart's
bart's the guy who's like let's get this
done aren't we supposed to procreate and
the chick's like what the [ __ ] let's get
on with this that's what this is for all
right that's why he's getting his dick
right here he's all semantics wait i
can't be hard what's the point
damn that's weird
point is we're going to take you to a
strip club it's really not to disrespect
the women or anything it's just to uh
you know just give you a more worldly
experience that yeah i need more
experience i don't want to plan on
daycare games though does that mean
[ __ ] i don't know
every time a ring connects with the the
stick doesn't she go like ah
like isn't that some pressure and some
weight basically she's probably like
hurry the [ __ ] up
she's [ __ ] pissed this one's [ __ ]
sucked dude rings all hitting her in the
face like [ __ ] aim bro
you got stuck in this game we'll play it
on jk party this saturday jump down bro
we'll put it in bart's ass yeah bart's
what's the only ass that is worthy it's
whole yeah it's thick enough we need to
get like a stripper plus prostitute here
like someone that's done both and then
we can interview and see which jobs they
like better mmm that'd be good oh that's
true yeah that's actually fascinating
server is like less invasive in the
stripping world yeah
today's video is brought to you by
upstar if looking at your credit card
statements make you want to scream to
the boy like ah you are not alone that's
why upstart is here to help you see the
light at the end of the tunnel oh i see
my life
there's hope right there upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
you're paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt oh no
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a one fixed monthly payment that's
awesome upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and your current employment to find a
smarter rate for your loan with a five
minute rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans from 1 000 to up to
50 000
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after being accepted for
your loan wow that's very fast find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today by visiting upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record and don't forget to use our
url so that they know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined by your
credit income and other certain
information that you put on your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record very good
did you guys watch that uh movie zola no
it sounds familiar it's like it's like
uh isn't that the rock's energy drink no
i love it it's there is there
interesting
she go like the movie is basically so
she had a night of being a stripper with
with a friend that she just met and she
tweets about the whole adventure yes we
did that here it's going to be a whole
movie or did they
made it all right
yeah it's an 824 movie it's good you
should watch it wait what wait what what
is it what's godzilla girl had this huge
crazy like experience with this girl she
just met who was like yo let's go dance
like and i think was in florida and so
she goes on this crazy adventure but
she's like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am i doing
she's tweeting oh she's live tweeting
she's live tweeting the whole time and
then and then you know it's such a
it's such an intriguing story and so
many crazy things happen that it's they
they made it into a movie and then it's
it's funny too because they utilize her
tweets throughout wow
and she says exactly what she's tweeting
so there wasn't a part in the night
where she was like actually maybe i
shouldn't strip right here randomly with
this random person um yes there were a
lot of moments like that but she
couldn't get out of it
wow it's intense
just reading the twitter story is pretty
nice can we watch this movie is it it's
coming out i think you can is it on
amazon it might be on amazon you can
rent it
zola zola sounds fascinating it's too
bad we can't go to the blockbuster and
get a vhs of it yeah the good old days i
know man look at that last one i think
it's in oregon there's one more yeah
there's one one last one dude who's
going there though do you guys have a
vhs player
i do not i want to see what this vhs
tape is that i have saved up but i'm
afraid that it might be a porno it
probably is for sure what do you think
it is like your childhood bike riding or
something challenge porno
yeah
and i remember my [ __ ] couch
yeah
and i recorded a porno on it or
something i want to see
i want to see it yeah i think it'll be
in you know their stores where i think i
don't know for vhs's but you can kind of
give them like old tapes and be like hey
can you put this on a dvd oh yeah they
could do that do they watch it though
yeah they're watching dude they're for
sure like being creeps about it
yeah i don't know it's i have found i
found a vhs tape zola tells all the real
story behind the greatest stripper saga
ever tweeted i didn't even know there
was like a category of stripper i think
it was the only one tripper sagas i
don't know it was pretty good though i
liked it
you said you read the i read though yeah
we did the whole story here on jk news
oh yeah yeah yeah you guys yeah you
gotta watch the movie
it's pretty crazy it's wow you sound
quite intriguing
dude yeah that's her friend
i'm literally looking october 28 2015.
everything's just happening in in this
this i don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening
what's happening i just pulled up all
the tweets right now for the first time
because i've never heard about this so
what's that what's an example first
tweet says y'all want to hear a story
about why me and this [ __ ] here fell
out it's kind of a long but full of
suspense me and this [ __ ] right here
next one okay listen up this law is this
story long so i met this white [ __ ] at
hooters waitress she came in and this
old ass big with this old ass big ass
black dude this is already funny tweets
this is great so you know as a hooters
girl we have to talk to our customers so
i sit with them and we get to talk and
she tells me she dances so i'm like oh
yes [ __ ] me too then she tells me this
whole king black man is a sugar daddy
i'm like oh yes [ __ ] um oh i'm like oh
yes [ __ ] my sd at home i feel it i feel
it sugar daddy yeah at home i was saying
san diego in my head so we're vibing
over our hoisin or whatever and we
exchange numbers and we like next time
you dance
come i'm gonna come dance with you and
they leave so the next day i get a text
like [ __ ] just go to florida and i'm
like huh she's like i'm gonna dance
florida let's go now sketch was
skeptical like damn [ __ ] we just met we
already taken hoe troops together but i
went to florida two months prior and
made 15k so low key i was down so i was
like okay i'll go let's go and when we
leaving all this [ __ ] says is be ready
by eight so i called her like [ __ ] i
said who's all going she says my
boyfriend our roommate and my roommate
uh and my roommate has a place in tampa
so i'm like okay okay okay i'll be ready
so i packed my badass stripper where and
i'm ready now my
n-bomb did not want me to go he was so
hurt so i had to [ __ ] calm
down
and then i left good this is exciting
now when i got in the car it was a white
boy her boyfriend and this hulking black
guy not the same one so i texted her on
the slick while in the backseat like
another sugar daddy you got a tight
[ __ ] and the black dude had her damn
phone so he starts laughing he goes i'm
using her gps no i'm not at sugar daddy
i've known her and her dude for eight
years we all lived together so jessica
the white [ __ ] pulls me to the side and
is like we're gonna be at the club all
night this room for jared not us don't
even trip so i was like yeah [ __ ] okay
but trust i am not laying my head here
so we leave our shed at the motel with
jared and head to club so we working it
was kind of slow it was early friday
night the club had hell of rules which
is why i'm not used which i'm not used
to i'm full of new type [ __ ]
but this club requires paceys and boy
shorts and all this other [ __ ] whatever
so after making about 800 i was ready to
go she was talking to some dude trying
to talk him out of his wall and they
exchanged the number so i was like call
your man i'm ready she calls the black
dude i'm like um that's not your man but
okay so i pulled it to the side before
he pulled up like what's up with your
roommate and she was like oh yeah we're
really close before i met jared i was
with him he was taking care of me i was
like oh well i don't need that she's
like taking care of me and stripper
language means that was her pimp so i
was like does jared know and she goes of
course not strike one so then she goes i
didn't make anything tonight would you
make because he's gonna ask i said um
that's not y'all's business jess chill
so he pulls up and as soon as we get in
he goes what y'all make we said at the
same time nothing so he goes damn my
girl said she had a bad night too we
finna go pick her up his fiance who
lives down here we pick her up and he
goes nobody made [ __ ] y'all want a trap
trapping stripper legal means trick so
jess goes hell yeah you got some clients
i'm going to back on you he was like you
can get some
so jess is like yeah i need a trap but
jared is at the room and he goes i
wasn't putting y'all in that [ __ ] hole
that was not for him not y'all that was
for him not y'all i'm still quiet we
pulled to a nice ass hotel on the other
side of town he goes i'll get the
clients together and text y'all all this
he handed her a trap phone so i'm mind
blown at this point so let me get to the
room nice as [ __ ] just me and jess and i
started going off [ __ ] you got me
[ __ ] up i'm not about to play with you
hoe i'm going home she starts crying and
she's like i didn't want to take this
trip alone please don't leave me i would
be so scared
she's [ __ ] sobbing i'm like omg
really now i'm feeling bad for her
though
she goes you can just check the guys in
he's not going to force you to trap i
said oh [ __ ] i know he not i killed his
dead ass
kill you i know i know he not i killed
deadass kill y'all this is really hard
verbatim so she cleans herself up and
there's a knock at the door i open the
door and some fat white man goes i'm
here for the white girl so i check his
pockets take his wallet and let him in
they start [ __ ] right on the bed next
to me it was a [ __ ] mess a mess so
when they finished he gave her 100 bucks
i said what you selling puss for a
hundred bucks
[ __ ] is worth thousands you tripping
she's right though this is like really
really good writing though so she like
actually starts helping her like make
more money throughout no way she's like
stuck in this situation where this dude
won't let her leave chelsea's work
because that's bad for the guy for the
girl
you saw the movie yeah i saw the movie
end so is it pretty like oh yeah it's
pretty accurate did you read the tweet
first or did you i watched the movie
first and then i that she read the tweet
first
this is all one tweet a great like it
just does she say [ __ ] that much in the
movie too
what because she's saying she's saying
[ __ ] is she playing herself she's
saying these lines whoa is she playing
herself
no
damn we got to see it faster
it sucks you went so fast oh yeah
because it speeds up so [ __ ] it moves
fast in the movie you're like this is
all [ __ ] so far tweet wise this is
all in uh the span of one hour holy [ __ ]
tweet wise yeah so it goes for like dude
doesn't she have time to do this she's
making 800 bucks
because she's telling a story that
happens it's not live tweets oh okay
it's it's later she she is like you want
to know why we don't hang out right so
then boom she's writing it all out
that's right i wonder if they met up
with her and got more details
um yes to make the movie yeah yeah wow
like to hear all the stories oh i gotta
watch this [ __ ]
like it just keeps getting deeper but
you know it's really everybody should
just watch the movie yeah just watch the
movie dude i would be like here's 20
bucks don't even give me a lap dance
tell me a good stripper story
all i see is a slit she says we're doing
this all night she [ __ ] about 20 dudes
and her sorry ass pimp only sent three
of them so around 1600 so she really
hooked up she hooked her up she got her
like 17 dudes
wow
killing yo
and then was charging them like way more
good for her she got paid out
i mean that's that's a very powerful
story i gotta admit i'm a little bit um
intrigued but i don't wanna i really
wanna watch the movie yeah don't don't
don't watch anymore because it gets it
gets crazier my favorite phrase is [ __ ]
him calm yeah [ __ ] no i know
hey babe can you [ __ ] me kong cause i'm
not calm right now
i'm manic
that scene is good too
i'm